hello nostalgia critic guy remember it
so you don't have to knock knock who's
there whoever rings is awesome
after winning critical praise box-office
praise
tons of Awards changing the way many
blockbusters are made and being one the
best known film trilogies of all time
who the hell is gonna argue with that
who are the rings went from being the
story that could never be filmed to the
best known film fantasy of all time but
that doesn't mean it doesn't have some
dumbass moments I mean with 558 minutes
of film of course there's gonna be
problems here and there and when you
have a film series that needs to bring
in a big crowd you need to take big
risks some of them pay off some not so
much
then hey it's still good to look over
the weaker aspects of a film because
truly no film is without flaws and it's
fun to review the mistakes and creative
choices that maybe in the future could
be tinkered with more especially seeing
how technically these films are still
being made allowing the subject I'm not
going to put The Hobbit films in there
seeing how they're still in the process
of being put out and I'm also not going
to draw too many differences from the
books it's an adaptation things have to
be changed I get that I'm only judging
these goofy choices in the realm of the
film's themselves so let's look over one
of cinema's greatest accomplishments by
acknowledging its top 11 greatest
downfalls why top 11 choose me search
ready this is the top 11 dumbest Lord of
the Rings moments
Oh
keep an eye
number eleven just letting Gandalf die
yeah kind of shocked nobody ever talks
about this one in the book as well as in
the animated movie when Gandalf is
facing the Balrog the power of uses the
whip to drag him down with it
causing Gandalf to shell fly you fools
as he plunges to his down
but in fellowship he hangs on to the
cliff
most likely trying to make the line more
dramatic how about your foots but the
question is if he's hanging on to the
cliff
why is everyone just looking at him
nobody thinks to run over and actually
pull him up go save him he's right there
you still got time you little idiots no
I take it back
Frodo does it's won a few times he
actually tries to take action but what
do they do they hold him back
like there's no reason to I suppose if
you want to go out on a stretch you
could make the assumption that maybe the
orcs are firing at them but he'll if
you're just going to stand there and
look at him anyway the very least you
could do is be a moving target by
walking forward and picking him up but
um Boromir is like no no he's gone
bullshit I am I'm right here never
coming back haven't even loved yet you
must move on without him I could hear
every word you're saying then but he
told us to fly yes fly forward and grab
me please use it forever and I much
rather live the real one girlfriend is
gone oh fuck this boy tell me though I
never liked him it still makes no sense
whatsoever the only justification I can
have for this is that well it did give
us a cool intro to two towers
any come on that opening was awesome
even if they did land in a giant lake
and somehow ended up on top of the
mountain
in fact why were they concerned for him
if he could survive a fall into a lake
and yet still had this drink to walk up
to the top of a mountain time depict us
enough how about you fools
number ten
those bajillion endings yeah you all
knew this was coming on the one hand you
can't blame these people for having an
ending that goes on forever
I mean it's wrapping up three very big
very long movies lots of characters and
stories need closure but that's not what
I necessarily take issue with what I
take issue with is the fake outs every
other second it looks like the credits
are about to roll instead they keep the
plot coming at first it looks like it's
gonna end with Sam and Frodo together on
the volcano but then it keeps going then
it looks like it's going to end with
them reuniting but then it keeps going
then it looks like it's gonna end with
them in Minas Tirith but then it keeps
going and there's still five more
endings on top of it there's so many
goddamn fade outs in this film you could
confuse it for the ending of Clue here
the end of all things
how do you pick up the threats of an old
life
it doesn't help either that ending one
point who looks a whole lot like a
curtain call
ladies and gentlemen your longer the
Rings players here we pull in a Dominic
Monaghan is buried in Pippin jobbies
Davies is giveaway Orlando Bloom is
legis Viggo Mortensen is all gone Rudy
SM big scary eyes is fro and Sir Ian
McKellen as deep always enduring always
heartwarming and the laugh that is
fucking terrifying
please don't show that again by Jesus
mask
stop that now for a lot of people these
several endings are a big complaint but
I put it pretty low on the list because
honestly I actually do like the endings
I mean yeah there's too many and they
faked you out too many times but the
actual ending stem cells are very
poignant and kind of touching so on the
whole I can't be that angry at them
maybe just a little angry and a little
terrified
you
no or not
Gillies idiot moments so again when
making an adaptation as big as lower the
rings you can't go into quite as much
detail as the books can so well good
chunk of the time characters have to be
simplified understandable enough but
good god what did you do to give me ah
yes the dwarves that go swimming with
little hairy women at first he started
off okay he was simple and emotional but
still had a sense of honour and dignity
just one wolf getting worried out to
frost cracks but as the movies went on
he just got goofier
and goofier what you please have to talk
about except the consistency of squirrel
droppings and goofy
he went from being his own unique flavor
of bad acid just silly comic relief he
could have picked a better snap decision
even he seemed to realize that his whole
rights merely existed to get a chuckle
out of the real heroes it's true you
don't see many dwarf women but in fact
they're often mistaken for the Wolfman
my mission turn is giving rise to the
belief that there are no cloth women and
the dwarfs just bring out holes in the
grain don't believe me just watch this
scene and tell me if the punchline music
doesn't write itself it's ironic that we
would have to wait for a prequel to
actually get a dignified dwarf character
but until that time we only had Gimli as
the dignified representation of the
doorknob
sultry talk thank God he had as bad as
moments in there too because if not I
think this would be middle-earth
interpretation of dwarf blackface it's a
little tight across the chest so did
talk cookie
no right
Legolas is perfect moments if one
character can be too flawed than another
can be too perfect
again like Allah started out as a very
precise somewhat advanced hero in the
first movie but as the films went on you
start to wonder why he couldn't just
fight this war himself look at this son
of a bitch well everyone's doing their
best to fight off soldiers on ground
yeah aragorn's like hit Legolas would
you mind bringing down a 5-story
elephant come on you can do that in your
pointy eared sleep but the bizarre thing
is he can without even batting an eye is
there even a betta sweat on his forehead
why is it there who's even still a
struggle at elves deep at first it looks
like all the humans are gonna have to
fight but then what they suddenly get an
army of giant dinosaur elephant killers
this battle should be over in ten
minutes
look at the scene from earlier their
fighting skills seemed too good to be
true
haha we knew they would come with us in
descending order from left to right
resulting in this cool ass shot
everything is coming up oh but even with
all these badasses on their side helms
deep even than Legolas has to show off
by going shield surfing I'm sure that
was essential to taking out those five
guys you could have just as easily
killed walking down the stairs effect
I'm surprised legless didn't just end
this whole war in one fell swoop
he's so freaking perfect I'm sure he
could do it Legolas a great he is
borning it boy boy
fear not my flawed mortal friend I shall
handle this
like a motherfuck Google Legolas you're
too good to be true and that is
precisely the problem
our structures loggers never said those
close-up shots I've mentioned this
before how a lot of movies and shows
back then felt they needed to get a lot
of wide-angle close-up shots this would
be fine if the idea was to create an
uncomfortable scenario but for a while
it seems like a lot of Directors did it
just to be different an artsy and here
it's no exception
well this decision did tone down big
time in the other two movies and thank
God for that we had to put up with quite
a lot of it in Fellowship of the Ring
and don't get me wrong
sometimes it's coma for like this scene
where Frodo's about to put the ring on
at the Prancing Pony which by the way
might not be the best name for a place
like this I look at the atmosphere and I
feel more the decay mule but like is it
here it's supposed to be a little off
and uncomfortable so the close-ups work
but come on when Bilbo is just talking
normally do we really need to be this
close even when Gandalf is saying
goodbye look at that you can count the
wrinkles under his eyeballs how would
you like it if I filmed conversations
like this hey Malcolm did you hear they
might be getting a new judge for
American Idol yeah I heard they might be
getting a new host too
oh really you mean they're getting rid
of what's-his-name yeah what is that
guy's name again
he says Sechrist be safe I know we're
supposed to feel close to the characters
but good god we don't need to be this
close isn't she she say number six
Denethor just just down to Foca if
there's any character I think was more
over-the-top simplified in these movies
into this one and I know a lot of you
may disagree but I got some serious
issues with this guy everyone describes
him as a Shakespearean villain being
very complex and very sympathetic well
I'm glad you guys saw that but for me I
just saw a crazy asshole the whole time
he seems to have just two settings
extreme jerk or extreme nutballs yeah
when he's not frowning or slobbering or
shaking his head screaming that leaves
very little room to actually feel sorry
for him which I'm told is the intention
they were going for
lighters and odorous
it looks like there supposed to be a
real tragic element to it like he used
to be a dignified Stewart and has gone
mad with power
but there's just so little dignity you
can see in this guy
and I know the idea is that he's
supposed to have lost all his honor but
you're supposed to give some idea that
there was some honor there to begin with
and you don't really get that the only
time the guy actually had sympathy from
me was when he found out about boromir's
death and oddly enough when Pippin is
offering his services until my lord
release me of death and I shall not
forget it nor fail to reward that which
is given he does actually seem thankful
and somewhat kind in this brief moment
and I'm not saying we need a ton of that
but we just need more than what we got
but no we need obvious symbolism to show
that the decision-makers in their ivory
towers don't understand the French ility
of life mist and shadow
than she
Oh
I'm apparently benign come on if I
wanted slurping disgusting this I go
watch more Gimli even his death seems
over-the-top goofy just when they were
about to give him something close to a
remorseful moment what do they do what
this is a Lord of the Rings at the
fucking itchy and scratchy cartoon all I
gotta say is if you were looking to
create a sour fold Shakespearean villain
my guess is you need a little bit more
dignity than this we'll be back in a bit
until then let the emotional weight of
this scene
you
Fatman Kember nutmeg there's a saying
that nobody ever really dies in TV that
there's always a way to bring a popular
character back well the same definitely
can be said for lore the Rings movies
first they think Gandalf is dead then
they think merry and pippin are dead
then they think Aragorn is dead then
they think Frodo is dead
good god I thought the ending had too
many fake outs this is like a new world
record hell they probably cut this mouth
of Sauron scene from Return of the King
because it was twice that they did a
Frodo death fake-out I have a token I
was bidden to show thee know that he
suffered greatly at the hands of his
holes we've done this we've done this
already the whole spider killing him
thing it didn't fool us then it isn't
fooling us now honestly we just want you
to open your gate for a minute I got ass
that steward coaxes one if I thought
that the only reason Boromir never came
back is because Sean Bean has it in his
contract that he has to die in every
single role that he's in and stay dead
but everyone else if death is just a
roadblock that pass it's like they build
up that no matter what these characters
are fucking invincible look at this how
many times do they throw themselves into
an army of killers and never even come
out with a scratch on the funniest is
probably this one with Aragorn Gimli
that is fucking ridiculous this long
line of killer monsters all being taken
down by two men
none of them half the size of the rest
of them even in the final climax they
know they have nothing to fear listen to
how they talk shortens your death small
chance of success what are we waiting
for
we've done this a million times even if
we die we're bound to bounce right back
hell we have an entire army of dead
people it's like having a cold you're on
a commission for a bit but you come back
swinging nothing like walking through
the valley of the shadow of death when
that valley is just the size of a pimple
that is fucking ridiculous
number four
Edwin's life is now tied to the fate of
the ring hey now there's no doubt that
Arwen's role has been expanded in the
movie says to be honest I really don't
mind it's a bit of a sausage fest in
here anyway and hell even the woman who
does join the fight has to pretend she
has a sausage so having her do more
stuff I think was a welcomed addition
but then we get this really weird
nonsense
Adonis dying the light of the Evenstar
is failing
so gnomes power grows strength
wings uh how the hell did that happen we
get something about the light of
brouhaha that's now somehow tied to
Sauron growing because I have no clue it
was made up for the movie I guess as a
means to give Aragorn something else to
fight for maybe keep her more out of the
way so that they're being reunited would
mean more I'm not sure what the
intention was but brother doesn't make
no sense what is that like think she
gave up if it makes her mortal then how
come none of the other mortal people and
middle-earth are dying in fact if it
does make her mortal then how come they
were talking about how much it's gonna
suck when she stays immortal and that
other scene in fact hell they make
immortality look like such a bitch she
probably be welcoming death by this
point in most cases like this you could
say that it's explained in the book but
this was a new scene and talked in very
little detail about it the more thing
about it maybe would have been cooler
they wrote it that she went to fight
with the rest of the army she was
originally filmed in the helms deep
battle until they edited her out wouldnt
it be nice to give her a little bit more
battle damage than a branch from a tree
oh look at that scholars show she's
tough and pushes on after battling
prickly leaves I don't know if you can
expand the character at least do it in a
way that makes sense
until then look pretty cry and don't get
any edges Edwin's life is now tight
- something Hey
number three
salmon Frodo's gayness okay now let me
make one thing perfectly clear before
anyone has a heart attack if Sam and
Frodo were actually gay in the story I
wouldn't care help it be cool maybe
they'd be the first gay characters in
fantasy openly gay anyway but that's not
what bothers me what bothers me is that
the intention was not to show the power
of love it was meant to show the power
of friendship having a friendship and
being in love are two different things
there's the love you share for a person
you have an attraction for I want to
live the rest of your life with but
there's also the love for a determined
person who will always have your back
and be by your side and the reason that
bugs me is that this relationship well I
do believe unintentionally makes them
look more romantic than friendly is that
it's obvious Toki wanted to show the
strength of friendship for reasons of
nobility and caring rather than lost or
romance lust of romance is fine and we
see it everywhere in big epic stories
but that's not what this is about
this is about two people who care for
each other as the closest of companions
and truth be told there's only a few
popular stories I can think of that
really dive into that you don't often
see two people at the same gender who
give up their life for the other just
for the reason of friendship if it's
opposite genders fuck it almost always
hook up by the end of the story so
that's why I think it's more important
that a friendship element was played up
more than a romantic one and again I
don't think it was intentional but it's
still hard to ignore that it comes off
that way and so much of that comes from
just how frigging lame these lines are
let's just look at some of these scenes
again Frodo was really courageous wasn't
he dad yes my boy the most famous Syst
of hobbits and that saying along we've
left out one of the chief characters
Samwise the brave I want to hear more
about Sam
I wouldn't have gone far without Sam no
mr. Frodo
you shouldn't make fun I was being
serious so was i I'm just waiting for
Gollum to roll his eyes and say our
crust just prepares our album and even
the friendship / romance doesn't always
make sense
Frodo send Sam away because he think he
ate the last of the Landis bread
fair enough he's possessed by the Rings
and being manipulated by Gollum but Sam
actually starts to oblige until he makes
this little discovery what exactly is he
supposed to realize there so I didn't
eat it when his return had been a lot
more powerful if they didn't show this
scene if Sam just said fuck it he's my
friend I'm gonna go and fight for him
anyway that would have been a lot more
noble but no he had to realize that he
didn't eat the bread that he realized
already he didn't eat huh like I said I
don't think it was intentional but the
more cheesy these scenes are played out
the more you can't help but think of a
corny romantic novel so you can't act
surprised at the comparisons and I think
we all know there's plenty of those
granted at the end the relationship does
work Sam gets married Frodo goes on his
own path and they do share a connection
you legitimately believe in just maybe
you believe in it a little more than
what was intended I can't carry it for
you but I can't carry you
number two
Sahra whoo there is no doubt that the
biggest fuck you to a character came
with Saruman the only human villain you
had throughout any of these movies was
completely left out of Return of the
King what the hell
he doesn't even make it appearance a way
of goodbye or anything he just doesn't
show up this is the guy that was the
center of the poster in the last film
you're a major villain second to only
that giant eye thing you and he doesn't
even get a little wave goodbye what a
liftoff now in one sense you couldn't
make the argument that Sauron is really
the villain so you don't need to spend a
ton of time with Saruman anyway but
there's two big problems with this one
the excuse that they give is not to go
after it that he's too harmless now to
do any real damage fucking what well
let's just have his head and be done
with it
No
isn't our power and the filth of Saruman
is washing no way yeah he's learned his
lesson I mean come on what are the
chances of an ancient evil that we don't
kill all the way possibly coming back
and biting us in that doesn't count he's
an i and ii they had a perfectly good
scene of him shot and added it already
yeah if you go to the extended edition
it's right there right at the very
beginning in tights of all loosens that
the connection between him and Grimer a
final send-off between him and Gandalf
and yes they don't just ignore the big
evil genius who could obviously cause
trouble later he's killed off and in a
pretty cool way I might add
well I'm sure he can survive that maybe
not
I guess the scene was cut for time which
normally I would understand for a film
this long you don't want to overstay
your welcome but it's the second scene
in the movie nobody's gonna be bored by
the first few minutes really do you
think anyone was gonna watch this and be
like oh this first two minutes isn't
grabbing me I'm sure the next three
hours will be more eventful God if it's
a time issue
why didn't you shorten one of the other
kajillion endings that you had that's
where people started to bitch and moan
they didn't need to know every single
detail that went on after the war was
over but we did need to know what
happened to one of your biggest villains
in the entire film series of course we
always want to see the bad guy get the
short end of the stick in the end but
next time try letting us actually see it
because that short end of the stick can
impanel pretty nicely
hey Gundam do you still have that
two-for-one coupon I could get you an
extra life at the pearly gates I already
used a new crop and the number one
dumbest Lord of the Rings moment is
those Eagles that could have stopped
everything everyone in the world brings
it up and of course so am i why don't
these creatures of awesomeness just fly
over Mount Doom and drop the ring off
themselves it's obvious that if they
wanted to win this war quickly and more
logically they would have used these
damn things from the beginning and every
excuse that people throw out in terms of
the movie never holds water oh well
there are Eagle gods who don't want to
get involved in our world affairs
well that doesn't stop them from
interfering one two and all three times
and all this well they wouldn't be able
to get very far the evils of Mordor are
just too great oh I don't know they made
it to the gate they seem to be fighting
off those ring rape things pretty good
and even if they didn't you could have
gandalf nightlight reflect them off like
he did before he doesn't seem like
Mordor has very
many of those evil flying things well
much like Gandalf they would have been
tempted to use it themselves and become
evil in the process for what a two hour
flight
if Frodo can resist for days on end I
think all the wise spirit gods can hold
out as well and shit how the hell they
can put that ring on a claw anyway whoa
they stick out too much a sneak attack
makes much more sense in the grand
scheme of things really because how many
times do Sam and Frodo get spotted
captured and injured for every day it
takes them to walk on foot thousands of
lives are probably being lost let's face
it people it's only by pure fucking luck
that this plan worked at all even
Gandalf several times in the movie
acknowledges this was probably the
dumbest strategy they've ever come up
with I've said oh why the hell did I do
it is I should have used the Eagles I
think all of us know how the ending of
this film really should have gone down
let's go back to that scenario we
demonstrated before I have a token oh
yeah yeah yeah
the dwarf say Merry Christmas
motherfucker whiskey
even the series how it should have ended
gave their take on this well that was
incredibly easy girl stirred walls can
you imagine what it would be like if
we'd walked the entire way don't be you
can make up whatever excuse you want you
can say that some way or another this
was the right thing to do but for me
this is by far the dumbest Lord of the
Rings moments now let's count down the
most awesome lore the Rays moans oh wait
we can't cuz it's too fucking many
despite these problems and I'm sure even
more that exists it doesn't change the
fact that Loretha rings is one of the
best film trilogies of all time it gave
so much it changed so much and as much
as we like to poke fun of it there's
still just too much to like about it as
for me I'm off to partake in the ancient
middle-earth art of dwarf tipping I'm
the Nostalgia Critic I remember it so
you don't have to salted pork
I shall handle this mist
where